hello everybody hope that you're good I
think I like this newer style of videos
that is basically one or two videos a
week in which I go from the weekly time
frame or daily time frame and I go into
lower time frame to the 4 hours time
frame to the 1 hours time frames and I
start to um find different setups and
triggers and I explain to you in advance
so then you can keep an eye on the price
action and uh maybe the video helps you
to I ify something new which I hope that
the last video did because we were
talking about the idea that this drop
here was a deviation same as here okay
and it's something that cost me qu of
critics not here in YouTube because I
have my small community and um I'm more
respected but on X I would say the same
but in X on x I get I reach to other
random people and different people don't
follow me and don't know who I am and
obviously I understand them because when
you see a everybody being bearish and I
don't know the whole sentiment across
the market was negative and thinking
that okay yes we were in a Range this
was a deviation but this looks different
so that means continuation to the
downside and everybody was talking about
buying at 50k or even lower than 50k
I've seen and I don't blame them to be
honest I don't blame them but um this is
a a lesson not for me but from the
market that you have to be prepared for
anything to happen and you don't have to
to marry to one Theory because the
market doesn't behave like that okay
each trading moment in the market is
unique it doesn't get repeated and this
is a very famous quote in the trading
world and I really agree with it because
that's why people are often wrong and I
mean people as a the general retail
Trader thought imagine hundreds of
thousands of Trad ERS okay and plus 90%
of them think that the same thing is
going to happen usually the 90% are
going to be wrong because the market is
going to trade against them and that 90%
of the market is believing that scenario
because is that has is that what has
happened the last time okay and also
because well they were releasing news
about the ger Market selling about I
don't know call it what you want the
market was in a very delicate point of
breaking below a range with negative
news um but then we had the CPI data and
I was talking to you about it in the
last video too okay you go employment
data coming higher CPI if it came lower
than expected which it did then that was
going to trigger the well that was going
to be the Catalyst of this deviation
okay and that's what happened so don't
marry to one Theory I don't know if I
helped with that video to any of you to
at least don't lose money in in that
moment and if so I'm very happy for that
that's why I make these videos for for
yourself not for myself cuz I don't gain
anything with these videos I just enjoy
making them but anyway let's go into the
chart okay so we're in the daily time
frame let me Mark the range as it should
range highs and these are the range
lows and we got the deviation here which
actually was a very clean deviation
because if you notice we had a very long
week right here and I always say that
weeks are imbalances and therefore they
have to get filled I would say that plus
95% of them get filled and when they get
filled we consider them to be filled
once they they've been filled at least
the 50% level okay so you can mark the
50% level of a week and that would be
the target to consider the week to be
filled I don't know if that was clear so
yes you have this week here so the 50%
level was around here and and you can
see that it got filled with this other
candle right so um any imbalance that we
left behind was this week and it got
fill so this is very clean okay
therefore there is no reason to continue
going lower as long as you don't come to
the range lows testing a resistance and
maybe then yes you could see another leg
down but in principle we were
considering this to be a potential
deviation okay uh and I was expecting
more resistance and the range lows
although we got them let go let's go to
the 1 hour time frame we got that
resistance there because if you notice
here in the 1 hour time frame we were
for how many hours around 15 hours yes
15 hours of getting re reactions from
the from this level okay from the range
low so you can see how he acted the
resistance for almost a whole day but
then price broke that level retested
continue now the question is is that
iing off of a retest I'm not sure
because this is the one or time frame
but if you go into the I don't know into
the daily time frame for example you're
going to see that there hasn't been
really any uh retest in the area okay so
um I would say that the key important
things to notice now is that we are back
inside the range and I've here a couple
of ideas why this might not play out and
I'm going to to the B them right now
because um they are not very strong
arguments the first thing that I've
heard of is that uh this is a potential
deviation and it doesn't make any sense
because that's not how deviation works
okay you have a range you have a
deviation you still in the range you
have another deviation you still inside
the range you cannot have a v deviation
like this it doesn't make any sense so
uh no uh I mean in fact that you are
back ins the range it confirms that this
was a deviation and now again you're
back inside the range because that was a
deviation of the range so that's not um
a strong argument to say that price are
going to continue going lower and then
we have another argument which is the
CME Gap okay so I think I have the CM
Gap here you can see how uh we created a
gap from here from
57,000 800 to
61,000 that's a c Gap because it's a pum
that happened during the weekend you can
see that this candle here is Friday and
there is a gap until Monday okay so
Saturday and Sunday um any move outside
where
we beyond Friday close it creates a CME
Gap okay um a gap in the Chicago mercant
Exchange so you can see how other gaps
have been reac and you can see for
example this one here is of a similar
size from
39,000 to 40,000 and what happened here
guys if you notice price didn't go back
to that CME gap
for a month and a half okay because this
Gap was created during the 2 and third
of December and we actually fill this
Gap the 22nd of January it took a month
and a half to get back there okay so no
it doesn't mean anything that we have
this C Gap it means that it's likely
that price goes back to this area but it
can be a weak or um usually it's a week
when we have a small CME gaps like for
example I don't know you have that one
there the gets filled St away and also
for example this one here that is Tiny H
but for example pay attention to this
this one here it doesn't end up being
completely filled so this one for
example could take even a year but
anyway what I wanted to say is that when
you have a big gap like this it usually
takes longer to get filled or okay it
can take a month it can take two months
it can take a year it during during this
drop go to the go to the Daily time
frame what in the daily time frame okay
during this big drop
here we created some gaps here okay and
if you notice we fil them how many
months later is this okay so look this
one is inun June and this one is in May
and we filled the one in June in April
and we fill the one of May in October so
um a year and a few months later that's
so you know you doesn't need to get fil
St away in fact look at this one you
have here a CME Gap from March that
hasn't been filled and maybe it takes 5
years to get filled so um a c Gap it
means that yes there is an imbalance
there in the chart but
it doesn't mean that it's going to get
filled immediately it can take a very
long time so um no guys it doesn't mean
anything okay it doesn't mean that
because we have a CM Gap that price is
going to go and fill it to St away it
doesn't work that way okay uh so yeah
those are the two arguments that I
wanted to uh talk about because um I
think many people are talking about the
CM Gap and careful with that okay it's
what I always tell you don't marry to
one idea it can take months or years
before we get again to the price level
okay and what else I want to say okay
daily time frame if you notice right now
we above the daily 50 Ma and we just
tested a support now let's see how price
how this candle closes today but I would
consider that this is a uh closing with
a week so price probably would have to
go low and this until this week but if
you notice this projection that I have
here what we were anticipating was a
push above the range lows that's what
we're seeing now actually went a bit
further and a retrace okay so perhaps it
happens perhaps it doesn't happen
because it's the same now many people
are waiting for this retrace and perhaps
it doesn't happen for that reason
because when many Traders are waiting
for the
retrace sometimes the market doesn't
want to give it because doesn't want the
through Trader to be in profit in a good
position so perhaps it doesn't happen
but my point is that if he actually
happens if you actually come again to
the range lows then I would expect this
area to be um a strong support again as
it's been previously for example here or
in all this time here or here okay so we
could see a push up from there so that
would be the area where I would open
more Longs if you get that okay and why
would I open long CA well because simply
and I will just be playing the range we
have a deviation here price goes to the
range highs we have a deviation here
price is going to go to the range highs
that's the next natural Target after a
deviation okay is the other end or the
other extreme or the other side of the
range also if you notice here look at
this yellow line This doted yellow line
is basically um marking a strong
resistance that is not the range highs
because the range Highs are actually the
the as it says the high of the range the
four is that one but this yellow dotted
line is marking a strong resistance and
if you notice we've left here between
the yellow do line and the white line a
lot of uh liquidity because all this
area hasn't been hit hasn't been touched
those Highs are still there okay and
usually when you see that there is a lot
of liquidity here so uh to me the two
the two Targets to the upside are two if
it would be this highs up
here okay between the yellow line and
the white line those highs and also you
have a lot of liquidations right here
between
67,500 and 69,000 so all this area
here that is full of liquidations too
right that means that if we get a
retrace then I want to open longs to get
here a take profits and here the other
take
profits all right I hope that was clear
now if we go into lower time frame and
this is something I like to do go to the
four time frame let's try to break this
up a bit more you can see how we have a
very strong relationship with the 4H
hour 50ma look at this guys since we've
been going down resistance resistance
resistance resistance let's continue
more deviation and then resistance here
okay here also
resistance and we haven't tested a
support yet guys so um if you notice now
the 50 ma it's in this level it's going
to continue going up and that could mean
that perhaps we see that retrace and
that is when I would see the range lows
holding also the 4our 50 holding tested
at support and continuation to the
upside
okay so uh right now to me the most
interesting chart at the moment is the
4H 50 May because I'm waiting to see
what happens what I would imagine again
I say imagine because I don't know
what's going to happen I don't have a
crystal ball is the price starts to
consolidate here for that the 4 or 15 me
is going to continue crawling what going
up slowly
and this is when we could see a sharp
retrace maybe a week or maybe a strong
candle body toou around 61,000 60,000
60,000 I far to be honest okay maybe
61,000 or so to leave some
orders uh not hit there we'll see what
happens and from there price continue
going up towards this area here of
liquidations that I show you and also
towards these highs here that haven't
been hit yet okay so if we get some like
this consolidation 450 me continues
going up and then we see that rra that's
what I want to open more Longs okay
because I want to write this wave up
towards the liquidations and towards the
highs that have that haven't been hit
yet so that's what I want to say in the
4 Hour time frame now in the 1 hour time
frame if you notice here we've actually
tested the 150 m
you can see there and price seems a bit
overextended I mean this helped to
reduce the overextension but still I
imagine that we're going to see
consolidation here okay maybe we see
consolidation and price breaks up to the
upside and go way to 68,000 but when you
see this consolidation in this area is
when we have to pay attention to for
example weeks to the upside price not
progressing any further that means that
the that the market maker was well would
be preparing shorts and that would
signal that retrace that I'm talking to
who knows 61,000 for example okay so
that's what I want to pay attention now
I'm simply waiting to see if we get that
consolidation area here okay and if that
is the case how is that consolidation
going to look like is it going to look
like w to the upside or if it's just a
simple consolidation like this with not
Wix to the upside that means
consolidation before continuation all
right so um I'll be updating about this
in the next few days but for now I'm
just waiting also what else we have a a
this is a long week let me use the
indicator we
strategy let's see what it
says yes it marks me that week I mean
the the whole point of the indicator is
that it Mar the the weeks as my eyes do
okay so H this indicator is trained to
to see the wigs the same as I do with my
own eyes so you can see that IM marked a
week here you can see fading away those
levels because they've been filled by if
I zoom in you can see how that was
marked and now it's marking this week to
the downside and maybe we're creating a
new one here all right so having this
week to the downside it means that price
could drop again towards this area okay
so again who knows consolidation here
Works to the upside but price not
progressing any further and that would
signal that we're going to see a retrace
and for that also you have the
Confluence of this week only if price do
something like this and consolidates
like this that would be different
because it would have failed this week
and the consolidation wouldn't be really
at the highs like here okay it would be
lower and that could mean other things
but for now all I'm want to do guys is
wait to see what happens and go back to
the Daily time frame something that I
mentioned in my last video
was it's risky to open a swing long here
but we can take advantage of this move
as a day trader that's why I open a a
position at the 50% of this week I also
had a position at the 100% that didn't
get fil but I traded this move here I
close my trade at the range lows as a
day trader now if we actually get this
drop to the range lows I open a swing
long as a swing Trader okay and that
will be towards the range size so that
is what I'm waiting for in terms of a
swing Trader okay so that's pretty much
everything that I want to say guys I
hope that video comes handy and it's
helpful and if so let me know and I'll
be happy to update more videos so thank
you so much for watching guys hopefully
this plays out and I'll see you soon